I'm Eddie Brock
I'm a reporter
Now I always seem to find myself
questioning something the government may not be looking at I
Found something really bad.
and I Have been
Look around the world. Who do you see?
a planet on the brink of collapse
Human beings are disposable like man and symbiote combined
This is a new race near species the higher life-form
What do you want upon me
We cannot just hurt people
We have a deal I clear so many tracks from the little time
To that power it's not completely awful. You have no idea how much you're scaring me right now
And you just might survive guys you do not want to do this trust me
Oops, we'll always come at a cost
You will be this honest wigglin faithless people going down the street
Oh, I have a parasite yeah neighbors chant
Hey everybody, its charlie
We got to break down this new venom footage as you could tell it's pretty much the comic-con footage
They showed off with Polish CG
It looks way different
From the original trailer like even his tongue in this one shot here already looks a lot better than the last time the whole idea
Here is them just showing off what the symbiote can do if you're brand new to the channel
Be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
There's a new round of that infinity war blu-ray giveaway - all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
And leave a comment on the video, even the voice of the symbiote sounds a little bit different. It sounds a little more
Identifiably Tom Hardy at this point before it did kind of sound like somebody different
I thought it was Tony Todd when we first started getting a full body shot
So you see there is no spider symbol
But there is a discernible white veiny
Pattern that might evolve throughout the film like this is a little bit better than the CG in the last trailer
I imagined by the time we get to the next trailer it'll look even more polished
There are three or four new really important symbiote shots in this - there's the expanded version of the one that we saw
Ending the last trailer where he comes up off the bike. We are venom. It's completely different dialogue
it's him talking about eating all the various organs this sort of the
Companion shot at the end where the symbiote bites the head off that mugger. Oh, sorry
I have a parasite is he just
Casually walks out the shot that proceeds this shot right here where it looks like he actually gets chased off the bike
He gets all of his bones broken
but the symbiote heals them right away and then a couple of shots throughout the trailer - where he uses it as a shield to
Stop all those bullets when he's in the building trying to protect his girlfriend then full-blown shots of the riot symbiote
So that's actually the one that they're bonding to this person here at the beginning
You see a much better shot of it in the container here when they first find it
It's meant to be silver even though there's a little bit different from the comics
They just wanted to distinguish it from the Venom symbiote because during the lethal protector storyline when they created the five
Offspring of the Venom symbiote to create those other ones that he had to take down
It was actually forced
Offspring in the way the director explained the new backstory of the different symbiotes in this film is that there is a pre-existing relationship
from the Clint are where they come from their alien planet, so when they're making their bargain, he's like
What do you want me for in the Venom symbiote says you'll soon find out it wants to take down the riot
Symbiote it needs Eddie's help to do that. So Eddie's this investigative reporter
He's trying to take down Carleton Drake because he's a dirtbag in the life foundation
But on the other side of that coin the Venom symbiote wants to take down the villain of the film
Which is the riot symbiote who you see jump into a bunch of different hosts during the trailer. So ultimately is actually Carleton Drake
That's going to wheel the riots symbiote at the very end of the film when you see them ripping each other apart here
This is closer to the end of the film that's supposed to be
Carleton Drake this in the riot symbiote the thing about venom, you know post-credits theory
I think that he's gonna be the stinger in that during this fight here
one of the symbiotes will actually
Reproduce the little bit that gets like sliced off and becomes another symbiote in its own right will be the carnage symbiote
So I'm guessing you know, venom probably victorious at the end of the film
I'm hoping that it's the Venom symbiote like the comics because carnage is the offspring of venom
But the way they're presenting the Riots symbiote is that it's like pure driven crazy
So it almost feels like they might change that a little bit
So don't be surprised if carnage ends up being the offspring of the riot symbiote
Just remember that they're changing the backstory the symbiotes how they get to Planet Earth
There's no discernable spider-man in this equation, which is why he doesn't have the spider-man symbol on his chest
It's sort of their way of tiptoeing around that MCU weirdness
like I said
You know big long-run theory is that they're just trying to wait and see how this does in real life
The interesting thing too. Is that the week that this comes out? It has no natural competition at the box office
So there's actually a pretty good chance that this movie does pretty well that was originally going to be that Andy Serkis Moakley movie
But then Netflix bought it so it's not gonna get a theatrical release. They'll just release it on Netflix
So there's no other big movies coming out the week that this comes out
So we'll see how that helps it. But just let me know what you think of the look of the symbiote
So now that you get the full body shot of venom or at least a more polished version of it
I'm sure by the time the movie comes out it'll look even better and the look of the riot symbiote now
We have more context for what this scene is where the office gets cleared is basically the riots symbiotes
Just lashing his blades out chopping all these people's heads off
this shot here of the symbiotes actually talking to Eddie is what I was talking about when I posted my Comic Con video so that
It becomes a little more visually engaging
When Tom Hardy is talking to the symbiote because it talks to him
Inside his head and this type of shot is right out of the comics, too
Like the symbiote has its own will it needs Eddie to survive because that's how all symbiotes work
It's the same thing with the riot symbiote - so we'll get a little bit more of the story in the next big trailer
originally
It was just meant to be a really cool black costume for spider-man
Then later writers tried to expand the symbiote cannon and give it a little bit more depth
But like I said this big fight here with them
slicing the crap out of each other just ripping each other to shreds I think is the path to the carnage symbiote being born from
one of these two getting the post-credits stinger setting up the sequel because the director did say that they wrote a
Special sequel moment at the end of this film like they are intending there to be a venom - whatever they end up calling that
What'll happen is there's a whole bunch more infinity war blu-ray bonus features and deleted scenes
I'll be doing a video for one of those necks. That should post the next couple of hours
Congratulations to the latest giveaway winner from my last big video Erik kill monger. Please email me on the back end of my channel
So I can get your contact details click here for the infinity war blooper reel and click here for that
Deleted guardians of the galaxy scene. Thank you so much for watching. Everybody. Stay. Awesome. I'll see you guys tonight